hey everyone it's Mike from waterfalls
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you can join me for today's video
we're going to be talking about uh
imbalances
um you know there was a question from a
user Devil's Hunter uh hosted this uh
last week says what percentage in you do
you use in your platform to Signal an
imbalance now
I use 400 percent which is four to one
okay the industry standard I I feel is
four to one I mean most people I talk to
use four to one you can see it here in
my settings imbalance uh trigger in
percent is uh defaulted to 400 I know
um other people use like to use 300
which is 300 which is three to one I
personally I find four to one is strong
enough for me
um I find three to one you know if
you're using three to one you're going
to get obviously more imbalances I know
people that use five to one I know some
people that use ten to one and
ultimately it comes down to what you're
comfortable with you know I find four to
one gives me enough uh imbalances that
you know I can make some decent uh
trading decisions based off of you know
the higher you go in percentage terms in
strength uh the less signals you're
going to get and it you know to me
imbalances you know is always been one
of sort of the cornerstones of order
flow and
you know one of the real benefits of
looking at a footprint chart is being
able to see an imbalance taking place
you're not going to see that trading a
dome right because you can't process
that information fast enough
um you know on a heat map or a book map
or something yeah you're going to see a
bigger bubble I guess but if you're
looking at a bar chart
right I think I got a bar chart here
you're not going to see imbalances now I
know you know there's certain groups of
Traders out there they like to mark up
their charts saying oh you know this is
a you know here's an imbalance taking
place you know from here to here
you know they'll say oh you got an
imbalance in the market or something
like that
um you know and it's like how do you
know
how do you know it's really an imbalance
right by definition what is an imbalance
you know it's a balance it's something
out of balance and if you're looking at
the actual buying and selling taking
place you can actually quantify it as
opposed to just sort of saying yeah well
there's an imbalance here because the
wick of the candle before uh didn't
overlap the wick of the candle
afterwards of this bar in the middle
okay that's really just price action
okay in my opinion now
you know we all have opinions in the
market and that's just that's just facts
you can't say something is an imbalance
based off of a price action move if
something I mean the whole concept of
markets in in balance and out of balance
you know goes back to you know Market
profile right and understanding balance
in the market and as the market moves
away from a value area that's your
imbalance so
doesn't matter what type of chart you're
looking at you know whether you're
looking at this is a time-based chart a
range-based chart
you know there are certain types of
imbalances that I like to see okay so
let's just start with some of my
favorite ones okay people say you know
what are things you like to look for in
the order flow I like to look at
imbalances in the market okay now
what I have on since imbalances is such
a important part of my own trading what
I had my programmer do years ago right
and I think it's been copied by a few
other software out there but it's one
thing to look at stacked imbalances okay
let me just turn off um
turn off the value areas first I don't
want to just confuse people
um disable the value area here and I'll
turn on stacked imbalance okay yeah
stacked imbalances are a great tool for
Traders to
you know see things in the market right
where there's aggressive selling right
here's a stacked selling and balance
down here
you know here's a stack buying and
balance coming in right here now
it's very visual to see where stacked
buying stack selling imbalances are
especially if you're
uh do I got the zones drawn out here let
me just double check uh
no I got it fixed
let's do it until tested here
okay so it's a little easier to see
there right so I see I got stacked
selling a balance as the market is
starting to sell off from the high I got
a stack buying and balance here right as
Mark is going up one here obviously one
up here at the high stack selling a
balance here
um these zones are drawn out if it's not
retested in the next bar when I use a
stacked imbalance I always want to I
always give the market some time to come
in and retest it okay because that's
that's sort of normal right what you're
going to see is you see like in this
case see a burst of selling if the
market sort of works its way back up I'd
ideally like to see more selling right
just as here right burst of buying
coming in Market pulls back if I can see
um some aggressive buying coming in here
you know that's going to get me more
interested but that's stacked imbalances
right that's very visual very easy to
see
um what I like to see is sort of things
that sort of take it a little step
further that's not necessarily
looked at by a lot of other Traders so
let me just turn off the Stacked
imbalances and go to multiple imbalances
down here under volume
um
let's enable multiple
imbalances meaning there's three or more
imbalances in a bar or three or more
selling imbalances buying imbalances or
three or more selling imbalances in the
bar colors you know you can change it
but I've got it olive drab and chocolate
um
you know when you start putting a lot of
things on your charts uh you got to make
decisions so you know multiple buying
imbalances highlighted here here here
multiple selling imbalances multiple
buying imbalances but where I'm going to
be looking for them
is around swing highs or swing lows now
it doesn't
take it's not rocket science to
determine if something is a swing high
or swing low you're looking at the chart
okay I see the market came pulled back
up here starting to sell off multiple
selling imbalances yeah I could be
looking for the market to continue down
okay
sort of bottoming it out here okay
multiple buying imbalances maybe this
Market's going to Rally it doesn't fine
um same thing you know at a low down
here low area the low of the day is here
multiple buying imbalances that's
bullish right okay Market doesn't go
anywhere
multiple sauna balances but you're at
your low of the day yours back and forth
I don't like when I get a bar with
multiple or Stacks selling imbalances
followed by a bar with stacked or
multiple buying imbalances I just stay
away from those bars completely and
again that's on a range based chart if
you look at a time-based chart let's go
to a minute based chart
um
get back
through the training day you know you're
at the high of the day high of the day
here high of the day here what's the
differences or even here
um multiple buying imbalances okay
that's what you expect to see you expect
to see aggressive buying coming in at
the high of the day if I'm at the high
of the day and I see multiple selling
imbalances multiple aggressive sellers
coming into the market that to me is
like
the market just screaming at me hey look
at potentially taking a short doesn't
necessarily have to come at the bar of
the high of the day come at the bar
afterwards or even a little bit later
right but anytime you get sort of a sign
at the high of the day for aggressive
selling coming in that's a trade you
know that you're going to want to be
taking a lot just as at the low of the
day
right this is our low here this bar doji
candle bar afterwards multiple buying
imbalances coming in
okay you see the market started working
its way up hold back again and kept
going up
and that's at 400 to 1 okay if I if you
uh again you know some people like to
set it higher at uh
you know gosh I don't know you could
even go say go ten to one one thousand
okay you're gonna get less imbalances
right here there's only two
here you don't have any selling
imbalances but in the next bar you've
got multiple selling imbalances the bar
after the high of the day just like here
the bar after the high of the day so
when you get stricter in terms of
imbalance settings right let's just go
back
previous day here take a look see if
there's anything interesting
or not nothing right here's that
multiple sound of balances but you're
already at your low this is your low of
the day at this point
um normal there's a buy here
multiple buying imbalances in this bar
but uh not a whole heck of a lot on sort
of these normal days here thin volumes
16 13 48.
um but you get the idea right
see if there's anything else interesting
um
this is the day before
this is the 23rd right you bottoming out
here
low of the day start rallying here
multiple buying imbalances at 10 to 1.
there's multiple sauna balances Market
just went sideways and again if you're
seeing multiple imbalances
here like this bar Even This Bar you're
looking for the market to start selling
off
right if this next bar trades one tick
lower and then rallies back inside
that's a bad sign in the order flow
you're looking for this Market that
starts selling off now why because I got
aggressive sellers here right now I'm
not looking for it to sort of go
sideways for five minutes ten minutes
and then sell off no you're trying to
take advantage of this right away just
as if you're down here and you're sort
of sticking up ticking up and then you
see the burst of buying coming in
you know it does pull back a little bit
then starts making that move I'd be very
hesitant you know even though I'd like
to get long off this I've been looking
for the move to happen sooner rather
than later right
look at this
right here's your multiple imbalances
right in the next bar you get that big
sell-off here you got a decent sell-off
here
okay now if you go to you know a shorter
or a lower rather I'll say shorter but
if you were to go to 300 to one
okay
you're gonna get more imbalances
okay so you're gonna see this bar you've
got multiple selling imbalances before
it didn't obviously this bar you've got
a lot more imbalances you got one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen I think earlier
you had uh
11 or something like that
um here you're getting a bunch of
bars of multiple buying imbalances
um you still got the multiple mine
imbalances here but now you got multiple
selling imbalances coming in
here as well
so you're going to get more signals in
that sense right is that something you
really want or not I mean you gotta make
that decision
um you know personally I I find 400
percent four to one
just nice you know it's a bit like
Goldilocks and the Three Bears you know
someone's been sleeping in my bed
this one's just nice you got to find
what works for you if you're
trading a market like uh so let's go
back to
here go back to treasuries okay
10 years well I don't want to use a one
minute chart I'd rather use a
choose a I don't look at treasuries on
minute chart anyway but if we go look at
the range based chart even if you're
looking at a five minute chart I'll show
that next you know at uh what do I got
here is my setting
400 right so four to one
okay yeah I'm seeing some decent buying
and selling imbalances
if I ramp this up
and the one
what do I see
a heck of a lot less imbalances here
I've only got one solid and balance and
here I gotta buying a balance here there
was buying a balance here earlier that's
gone
but I still see a lot of selling
imbalances coming in on this move down
okay
if I go to a shorter time frame or
shorter imbalance level
okay I'm gonna see more here I've got
multiple selling imbalances so again
depending on the market that you're
Trading
chart you're Trading
you're going to want to decide you know
hey what percentage am I comfortable
with me personally 400 or 41
is what I'm comfortable with
okay so again like I've always explained
trading is a personal thing you got to
find what works for you what works for
your risk tolerance
and go with it right it's one thing you
know I I last thing I want you to do is
go away all Mike says I have to use 400
well no maybe that's not right for you
maybe you know 300 is maybe 500 is it it
really comes down to you the market that
you're trading because again you know if
if I was in a different Market
um you know a more volatile Market you
know four to one I could get a lot of
imbalances
right and that's not something that you
necessarily want to do so for example
right this is an
NASDAQ right NQ right and this is set at
300 go on a three to one
right three hundred percent a three to
one ratio and you're seeing since you
know the bars got a bit of volatility
right Market's looking for liquidity
almost every bar or every other bar has
got multiple buying and multiple selling
imbalances so that's not going to be
very useful to you if you you know 300
to 400 okay you're probably still going
to get very similar results but if you
upped it to
1000 right ten to one so you see in here
right literally multiple you got one two
three one two three four you know
multiple imbalances
um that if you're a bit more stricter
going ten to one
you're going to get less bars with
multiple imbalances right here you got
multiple buying imbalances multiple
selling imbalances multiple buying
imbalances multiple buying imbalances so
that's one of the differences that
you're going to have to choose you know
decide you know based off the market
right so if it's a market that's got a
lot of
you know volatility so to speak
right
here
this bar is a big gigantic bar 9 52 and
three quarters all the way up to 74 so
about 20 point range
but with imbalances set at ten to one
you've got one two three four five
imbalances only if I had it set at three
to one
right we had five when it was at ten to
one when we're at three to one we're
gonna get a lot more imbalances right
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen sixteen
three times as many imbalances so it's
not going to be as effective in my
opinion as if you use a higher
percentage on a more volatile Market
okay so and I hopefully by now you're
sort of understanding the nuances of
imbalances uh what you can use what you
can get away with and you know hopefully
use it in your own trading so
that wraps up this video on imbalances
and you know again I hope you found some
of these tips and nuances useful that
you could apply to your own uh trading
so again let me know what you like to
discuss by leaving it a comment below
alright everyone thanks I'll see you on
the next video bye-bye